let's go to victor from california
victor you're on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
i um just want to kind of go over and
ask what you thought about this idea of
fake news do you think that
um kind of and by the way i'm a big fan
of your show and other kind of
commentary shows
thank you youtube but do you think what
we're doing
or what um kind of this move towards
hard news towards more commentating
um news is kind of uh creating more of
this
cloud of fake news in the world
i don't think i you said the move
towards hard news and commentating news
those are two different
yes right so right now when you look at
the media for example if you go to
fox news or you go to cnn a lot of it is
is kind of news interwoven with
commentary yeah so they'll report on a
fact the report on an event that
actually is happening for example if
like say a president is proposing some
new legislation or he's
signing in to lost something yeah
they'll report that event and then
they'll make some kind of commentary on
it right
and if i'm a viewer watching this what
i'm already doing is i'm already kind of
um
looking at what uh listening to what's
happening and getting a kind of
subjective experience
sure right so if i'm a conservative and
i watch fox news
or cnn for example and there's some
news that's being reported on and then
there's comment commentary
uh some kind of commentary that i don't
agree with i'll just automatically
assume that it's fake news and the same
goes with like a liberal watching fox
news
and so yeah that's moving towards
uh the hard news to more kind of uh
commentary and pun entry both from the
left and right kind of increases this
world of not only echo chambers but uh
this idea of fake news so your questions
your question is kind of complicated and
i only sort of understand
it but let me tell you a couple
different things one
um a lot of people if it if it's
packaged like a news show they think
it's just news
right so you look at fox in the morning
and then you see tucker carlson
at night and it looks pretty damn
similar so you're like this is all news
when it's it's really not
the other problem is there will be
commentary even in shows that are
supposed to be just news shows
that's that's another issue and a lot of
people aren't able to sort of suss that
out
and then the same applies to online
stuff you look at websites for fake
news news sites and real news and they
look almost identical
people can't tell the difference so i
don't know that the problem is
necessarily
that you're seeing the mix of news and
opinion
although you can argue that that is part
of the problem because of how
ignorant people are but really the
problem is the lack of media literacy
and the lack of people who can think
critically about what they're watching
yeah do you think though
it's like uh they're just naive or do
you think that um
like if we define truth as something
that could be possibly subjective
for example if uh um if there's a law
that
uh comes into play that lowers taxes for
example and i'm a conservative and i
believe that lowering taxes
helps stimulate the economy or am i i'm
a liberal that thinks that lowering
taxes hurts infrastructure for example
do you think that if i'm watching like a
new segment on cnn or fox news
then i'm going to agree or disagree
depending on my already preconceived
notions of this
yeah that's called confirmation bias
widely studied that that absolutely is
the case yeah
do you think that's kind of contributing
to this idea of fake news
or if it was just hard facts if it was
just i'm sorry if it was just hard news
all the time we would kind of just like
absorb the news and make that opinion
you know on our in our day-to-day
political lives whereas yeah
maybe i mean it's very theoretical and
it's just not the situation that we have
i do think the other problem is that
fake news is b so
opinions disguised as news are different
than fake news
fake news is a very specific thing it's
now being applied too broadly
what you're saying is blurring the lines
between opinion and
news reporting and that's that's
different than fake news but i think
there's probably more to say but but i
think you know i've kind of given you my
general sense of it
well i appreciate it thank you very much
all right there's victor from california
very much appreciate the call
let's go to a break i'm sorry i couldn't
speak to more people today but i will
speak to more people very soon that's
for sure